vous les faites prisonniers
business personnel entre eux et moi
logique pas de prisonnier que des
trophées
je crois qu'ils vont nous tuer oh toi
ton heure est venue
on est vos prisonnier avance on pourrait
pas en discuter on est entre gens bien
[Musique]
c'est vrai
adieu mon
[Musique]
ami tu es à moi
lâche-moi
il a besoin de moi
[Musique]
tourne toi
pour ceux qui en avait pas de mort
[Musique]
et toi qui meurt
viens
je t'ai apporté ici Bertrand ta patrie
et tu me persistes à défendre l'humanité
vous m'avez appris que la liberté était
un droit due à chacun
je rêverais le pilier pour cela devrait
me passer dessus
[Musique]
durant fort
on essuie les tirs envoyez les tomates
maintenant première formation en
approche
en priorité on couvre Optimus
redémarrer le pilier
les pieds
je ne peux pas les retenir on est coincé
par les vaisseaux
toujours le plus brave d'entre nous
mais incapable de prendre des décisions
difficiles
[Musique]
il n'en restera qu'un
planète
[Musique]
sauver un autre monde tu crois que tu es
un héros tu crois qu'un héros
seulement un messager
est encore connecté
toujours connecté cache
[Musique]
l'heure est au négociation tout ce que
je veux c'est reprendre le pouvoir du
reste
que deviendrait tu sens moi
c'est ce que nous allons voir
[Musique]
tout ce que je voulais c'était la survie
de notre espèce que tu dois le
comprendre pourquoi j'ai dû te trahir
vous ne m'avez pas trahi
vous vous êtes trahi vous-même